i mean there's probably super great good
players
yeah definitely i mean there there's uh
a lot of uh good players you know that
also
somehow lost their eyesight
but uh and then also you i mean
we are all all three of us are capable
of playing a game without seeing the
board true that's true blind chess yeah
yeah
so we could actually do a game you know
without seeing the board as well that's
true oh chess it's the it's such a
fantastic game it's for everyone and we
just love that okay and here we go game
three between magnus and young christoph
with a win
magnus will be the winner of this match
and is he going for that win well in
order to try and get that win at least
magnus is employing the english opening
and uh okay black's bishop coming out
now it's actually
just before this movie i was going to
mention it's the four night variation of
the english opening which you saw that
earlier this tournament four pillars
four pillars yeah those all the four
nights developing themselves really
early and white tonight actually here
for the second time jumping into the
center and this isn't necessarily the
most common move in this position uh
white's knight moving again but the idea
is that you kind of put some pressure on
black's bishop that's developed and uh
you don't really want to capture this
knight as black if we see a night trade
then white pawns will only centralize
themselves and black has to lose a bit
more time
so okay interesting strategy already in
quite a kind of imbalanced opening i
would say an opening that both sides
have reasons to be uh ambitious and uh
yeah interesting decision by magnus to
go in for this it's not normally what we
see from him these days but uh okay
black bishop retreating meanwhile
and duda he will need to know his stuff
in order to equalize and survive this
opening as black i've played it a few
times myself as white and there are some
tricks that black needs to know
in order to get a decent position in
fact the two are repeating a game that
they played in the world blitz
championship in 2018
and in that game magnus with the white
pieces won
yeah and uh dude
was that the tournament he came second
in the world blitz or was that one year
later it was in uh saint petersburg yeah
i played it oh you played that yeah yeah
yeah so he became must have been tripled
world champion right dude was second and
magnus won one of the events
and he was third in the other one ah and
uh one
after working with magnus uh dude went
and stole his crown uh in the world
rapid championship and okay both sides
meanwhile have castled white now pushing
a pawn
and uh he's getting ready now magnus to
push another pawn in the center of the
board
and i remember first reading about this
position actually i think it was in a
series of books by mikhail marin on the
english opening
and uh there marian was very optimistic
about white's chances
despite the fact computers often say
these positions are level white's plan
is clear pushing pawns in the center
it's maybe slightly more tricky for
black to decide when to capture white's
knight in the middle of the board or
where to develop his pieces to
do you have any experience here in this
type of opening process
uh
yeah i mean this kind of positions you
you hardly can avoid somehow you know
because uh you always get this uh
you have to play something against
english
and uh
i think most players play e5 no song
maybe c5 but e5 is
maybe the most common move yeah because
it's like a reversed sicilian you know
so therefore a lot of people
they tend to like to play like this
because it's something familiar from the
sicilian
so that you know already the key is at
least it was like that for me yeah yeah
i have played it on occasion but it's
always felt a little bit sharp because
the sicilian opening when you play it as
black feels incredibly wild and so to
kind of
give white the chance to play it with
one extra move
felt crazier to me so i never touched
didn't touch it too much so i preferred
kind of
well my light square strategy pick my
pawns
put my pawns on those light squares and
then play magnus laughing
yeah he's laughing at the your score
yeah
the timing was perfect actually
no no but the thing is that you and the
difference uh because i i've played a
lot of dragon i love that which is a
very very sharp sicilian variation and
therefore the difference here is that
you cancel the same size and that's also
what makes it actually playable
for for black because the i don't want
to play the dragon with the temple
temple down yeah
i think that will be
it's the most suicidal you can do inches
and meanwhile black's bishop coming out
it's interesting we talk about sicilians
because uh inside's game against magnus
age 10 that was an open sicilian so
there sad had white he was very direct
trying to open things up trying to go on
the attack and this is actually actually
a similar branch uh but as ponto says
with colours reversed so white is
basically playing a sicilian with one
more move and that means black doesn't
have the time to do what sad did and
open the position up and go on the
attack and uh
duda i think that type of thing would
suit him but here at least he is
creating some threats and this bishop
coming forward creating a pin uh on
white tonight and the queen behind it
does force magnus to make a decision do
you push a pawn force this bishop to
retreat
or maybe evacuate the white queen from
the same diagonal
a few choices here for magnus you could
push a pawn in the center just one
square stop black from advancing forward
black's threat is to push the e pawn
forward let's center pawn one square and
actually win a piece so magnus has to be
really accurate here yeah but the most
popular move incidentally by a long shot
is actually attacking the bishop and
asking it to make a decision
so magnus of course he doesn't quite
like to go all the way into the main
line he always likes to duck and dive
choose the little sideline that is
natural and fairly easy to play so i'm
quite interesting to see whether he
takes the decision now to follow men the
herd or play something a little bit
different and go his own way
but whilst we're waiting for a decision
i do i wanted to show you a nice selfie
from richard harding who
his pet chicky is complaining he was
once their intention but of course
richard is occupied with the commentary
and there you can see the cat
fighting for charlie the chess cats
attention
and uh eddie miller has an interesting
hypothetical question says that uh
they're a huge morphe fan how do you
feel today's top players would fare
against paul
morphy oh that's a tricky one meanwhile
as expected magnus pushing the black
bishop back um yeah it's difficult
because morphy
most of his games
that are available to us nowadays they
were very one-sided his opponents not
defending very well uh often he would
sacrifice pieces and the best way to
kind of rebuff the attack refute it is
to not accept but they would always it
was kind of a code of honor in the in
the 19th century to just take pieces to
allow your opponent to checkmate you
allow your opponent to attack and uh
yeah unfortunately these days all these
top players that you see they're
fantastic defenders and they won't even
really let you attack unless
i mean unless it just doesn't work so
morphy would have to evolve and play a
different type of chassis and he would
have been very really good of course but
yeah yeah and he would have played
different as well because it's like you
said because back then you were coward
you know if you didn't accept the
sacrifice really even if it led to to
checkmate or you lost or something like
this so it was like the social code you
know yeah you had to like more or less
take it even if you know what you would
lose the game and there is can you see
duda or
magnus or someone else doing that no
there is no chance yeah so murphy but he
was very talented you know and they
received even some movie about
actually port morphe called the oprah
game that uh
it's launched
so it's awesome oh i need to put that on
my list yeah it's a really good one
because we have a guy in the board
called ken mas that is actually
the director of that movie you know and
they
worked with also with spike lee and
with monte ross so so some of the really
good ones and it's it's coming out quite
soon okay so it's not out yet even yeah
it's not out yet the opera game the
opera game yeah oh wow wow i'm looking
forward to that yeah we all have to go
to the movies together that's gonna be
exactly yeah we have queen of cups as
well which is a great one have you seen
that one um i've i actually haven't seen
it but it's on my list because i heard
so much about it it's a beautiful film
and it really is
you should go home tonight and watch it
because i remember in 2010 talking to
the journalist who actually wrote the
book
and uh he was telling me about this girl
who'd actually risen from the slums and
was playing and represented a true story
yeah absolutely true story
and uh he was following her progress i
hadn't even heard of her and then
afterwards i i met her in 2013 and i
just had to say fiona you are a legend
wow absolutely fantastic yeah and she
she actually graduated now from
uh university in the states because
because of all this she
she comes from one of those areas in
kampala in uganda where you are working
yeah yeah exactly so it's it's not
exactly uh we have some some girls and
uh some kids from that area as well yeah
uh but she came from from one of the the
the worst uh slum areas so it's super
super super poor as you can see in the
the movie
and then she managed to
because of chess she learned chess she
got
you know people got interested in her
the media got interested she had a
talent yeah because she once started to
win tournaments so she came there
actually yes to get food because they
had free food that they're just training
so so she followed her brother yes to
get some free foods to to to get fed you
know and then
she picked up the moves
and she had some talent so she started
to win so she became a ugandan champion
and then she made it to the national
team and that led to the movie and that
led to a scholarship to the states
so she got a fully financed scholarship
and then she has now graduated and
started to work in finance and she also
created her own foundation
oh what an inspiring story
oh we have to invite her as a guest that
would be incredible to be able to talk
to to her and
talking about africa and and kids and
also girls
that's also an initiative that you have
in your business for chess and kids
a special program for girls as well what
is that about yeah we work together with
the lighthouse chess club which is a
very progressive chess club from kenya
and
jennifer shahades
u.s chess woman so and i'm use chess
federation so we work with them so
they're all partners and then basically
we have uh around yeah now it's like
around 600 girls in total from different
countries they're from uganda from kenya
you know from the states
from colombia my my native country ah
cool and and we have even from south
sudan we are from sudan
and then we have uh malawi botswana you
know from different so so these girls
they meet up
um
online yeah so have we teach them chess
but also a lot about
you know they can get a friend you know
so they
interact over the countries you know and
then we also have this confidence
training you know and they also
sometimes discuss food food
this is a very social program you know
so that's so cool to create those
connections when they're young girls to
maybe be able to travel abroad when they
get older to go to school or even exile
in chess of course exactly then they
play games uh against each other and
they also
exchange you know knowledge and and uh
so it's a really cool thing actually
it's called cross culture girls
and they also made the drawiest against
judith polgar
so that was a big huge for the girls
it's so inspiring the work you're doing
punches i love hearing these stories we
do have a few moves
let's take a look at them before we talk
some more about this yeah we do have a
few moves and a couple of things have
changed and uh if we just jump into the
position to catch up with what's
happened we saw it here white did indeed
kick the bishop back this is just very
typical i think 80 90 of the time if
your opponent creates a pin like this
just force that bishop back forced it to
commit the pawn stepped forward
attacking the bishop black doesn't
really want to trade off because this
would only help to activate white's
pieces the white queen now on a good
square so instead dude retreated and
magnus said okay
pins are just too annoying and he broke
this pin by pushing pawns this has one
downside that you do slightly weaken
your king but uh after the bishop
stepped back he decided okay it was time
to push another pawn hitting the other
black bishop every move magnus coming
with a threat and after this bishop
stepped back magnus took the bishop he
eliminated one bishop and now look at
this one he's traded one bishop off on
this side he wants to trade the other
bishop off on the other flank magnus
just playing a bit of symmetry here a
bit of mirror image he's going to try
and capture this bishop and we might
even see two bishops against two knights
one of the uh
most hotly debated type of peace combos
in chess and it's not clear who this
will favor for example if duda just
plays a sensible move improves his rook
okay he actually centralizes his bishop
but this
i think slightly favors white just
because this bishop is so strong on the
diagonal but uh either way we're going
to see some fireworks about to happen
because duda did not allow this he
planted his bishop in the center and
i don't think white wants to trade these
off if you capture the bishop suddenly
white's king is just too open it's lost
its defender also an attack opened up
against the white knight
so magnus he has committed everything
already to trying to get rid of black's
bishops he needs to push his pawn
forward and hit this guy block any
trades this will result in for example
duda either stepping back with his
bishop keeping it safe losing a bit of
time though or maybe this knight jumping
out of the way i'm not sure exactly
where but for example if it does jump
out the way yes you lose your bishop but
you counter attack against the white
knight and this one is heating up
definitely magnus has spent a lot of
time so far duda i think he's done a
good job of at least keeping this
imbalanced because he needs to win one
of these last two games you told me the
other day david but i forgot
when in what kind of positions do you
prefer the double bishops and then what
kind of positions do you prefer the two
knights if the center is blocked for
example if we see a trade here and then
the center just blocks itself up then i
think i prefer the knights the knights
are more flexible they can okay we're
actually heading in this direction uh
the knights can jump in any direction
they can jump to either side of the
board look how blocked in the bishops
are this bishop now just staring at its
own pawns it's blocked in and this
bishop as well
it's gonna take an age for that to get
active it's staring at its own pawn as
well so if the position is blocked it
tends to favor knights if the position
is open for example if these pawns all
disappeared from the center of the board
then the bishops have scope and they
have uh kind of at least a lot more
energy so magnus know how he didn't
block it up he didn't block open the
center he wants to open it later and a
small trick is that it looks like
black's about to win a pawn but after a
recapture black cannot get greedy and
take this
loose pawn because suddenly a discovered
attack the white bishop drops back
hitting the black queen but also a
discovered attack against the black
knight one of those two pieces will drop
so magnus using tricks he's going to try
and activate his bishop maybe this way
or maybe dropping it back to evict the
black queen from his half of the board
yeah and i was just going to say an
answer to your point kaya is that i
whenever i teach chess or whenever i
visualize chess um
i always kind of visualize the pieces as
kind of some olden day battle so like my
bishops are archers
and so you would never have an
archer looking at its own pieces they
need to work from above they need to
have that freedom that space and that
exactly
and uh rooks are kind of like your
cannons and then you're then you have
your old foot soldiers and you're just
the the general there you know you're
the mastermind and uh knights are just
like the they hop over things so i
always think of it like look at what you
got look what's in your toolkit
and
it is i mean it's nice i mean this is
going back to real real basics and
having fun with it and imagining things
better you know sometimes it's good to
sit back and take that step back and
just go hey what do i have what does my
position want what did they want to do
and remember you always have to give
very specific directions okay so now i'm
imagining my bishops with
yeah
you want to lengthen the diagonal that
they're on yeah because they need that
clear path they need that vision
forwards and backwards along the
diagonal
see i love these i bet you're using
these as well pontos when when teaching
kids chess these uh
ways of imagining the pieces and
different things maybe using names for
them as well yeah there are some because
we have uh
we donate equipment you know yeah and
then we have also employers a lot of
teachers in different countries they
teach these kids
so and in africa i actually had to
witness
or
head to business i shouldn't say
actually witnesses
uh some of those stories and it was
incredible stories you know that i can
never i can't even retell them but it
was about the lion and the king was lazy
or
it was just incredible stories that they
they were telling them and it and it
worked they're inspiring the kids right
yeah so all because there was a class
that they didn't know how to play chess
and after all those stories
after that class everyone could knew the
rules yeah so they work you know because
you just need something to hang it up
yeah and also you have the knowledge it
was really cool okay i love this animal
analogy even better than the arches and
whatever so what would be like a bishop
what animal would that be
like a
what is the most long range animal hmm
i'm thinking about that super speedy you
know the leopards the cheetah the
cheetah
let's see yep
yeah yeah because it can move quickly
and the rook can be the elephant just or
maybe that yeah
maybe a rhino maybe it could be a
rhinoceros
was a rhino
this was a prank
and then yeah the night of the night
yeah
yeah of course
something that jumps and then exactly
and then then it was uh
what's the queen
the liar no then now the lion there was
something with uh
the queen is a lioness well right maybe
the knight is the lion
no you have this uh jaipur that is more
feminine so there was like the equipment
that was the queen and then
it was the lion was like the king and
the bishop may be a snake it's just
snaking its way
yeah
oh this is fun anyways what's happening
on the board yeah just a couple of moves
but it is that battle it's the bishops
versus knights and
duda he's just trying to keep things
locked up just slowly moving pieces the
black queen
wow okay magnus really committing i'm
surprised about this one he does block
things up i said that strategically that
is a risky for white yeah and there we
go the evaluation by slightly in black's
favor now
white bishop's not happy about that yeah
i was expecting to just to keep
attention you know like queen yuan or
sit and wait transfer it to f2 or
something like you know yes keep
touching you know but but uh this is a
very committal move yeah
and also have you i mean you can see
this that magnus is he's going all the
time for this type of positions you know
with the two bishops
all the time you know yeah he loves the
bishops yeah and different openings the
same type of position so magnus is
basically arguing in this type of
position yes he knows that the position
is closed but
uh he caught he holds the
key to the lock he is able to open up
the position because he's in control of
the pawn breaks and if you do look at
the knights the knights actually don't
have that many great posts that they can
work together
there's one but i can see it's the
square on h4
but there's not a second one
yes in front of the the pawn there on on
the the last trunk air definitely it's
heading there
but it's do you do you remember when we
played this and i'm always going back to
this poland
you know no no but abdusatro that one
yeah yeah also talking about 16 year old
kids yeah i was 17 yes but but he played
similar positions
that was i mean it was this type of
position it was a also the english
opening a slightly different branch but
it was purely because of that opening
actually the bishop versus knight combo
that he won the world rapid championship
wow he won all games like this you know
just took the bishop played really fast
and then locked up everything and then
just started to attack them
he didn't mind blocking things up even
blocking his own bishops just to take
squares away from the opponent's knights
and yeah i think with the english
opening he beat was it with magnus
nepogniacci uh aronian girlfriend he
beat them all in similar
similar ways
and he also said also later to their
press that he had prepared us
before the tournament so maybe magnus
taking inspiration from abdu satoru how
cool is that and magnus was sitting at
just a couple of boards away every time
so he would be well aware of some of the
plans some of the concepts that abdu
satoru for showing and uh ivanka's right
the knights
right now at least don't really have
access to good squares so
uh interesting do you guys have a
preference in general knights over
bishops i know that for example we talk
about vichy anand the world champion he
loved his knights bobby fisher preferred
his bishops judith polka also liked
knights um
yeah
i really i like my bishops because i
find that they're simpler pieces
and especially when it comes to time
travel scenarios i always forget those
backward night moves and before i know
it the knight has kind of given me a
very crafty check
and i just feel that the bishop is
easier to kind of
get a grip over you know that it's going
to go on one color complex you can kind
of see that where they can maneuver what
diagonals they can go to so i'm a bishop
person what about you pontiff
uh well yeah i think it depends so much
on
what position you know
it's like you said before if it's open
yeah you know you like the bishop pair
uh but if it's close like this you know
you usually like the knights but abdul
satyar played in
in this fashion you know and i thought
it was very interesting the way he
played you know and also how successful
he was he beat all the the best players
with this way so
i i think this is a definitely
and this is uh when they talked to us
about morphy before you know this is
also a modern thing
no one would ever i mean if you had the
old days with those dogmatic guys like
taras and so on they you probably
wouldn't get shot you know if you would
suggest something like this
to close the game you know and then play
against with two bishops you know
they would have thrown you at least out
from the chess club yeah they would say
that you have no chess culture
you don't understand anything so
it wasn't just harass there's many
stories about bob winnick throwing out
uh several of our creative grand masters
i think krasenkov was thrown out
too creative to follow all the rules
right they had like there is a
dogmatic completely dogmatic book called
my system okay and where
they actually nimitz wrote down you know
his rules
and if you didn't understand those rules
of what or or even questioned something
you know you were
dismissed
completely did so you get out so
basically and i think that's also a
reason why why modern players are also
stronger of course because people are
you know questioning everything yeah but
back then you know it was not really in
the place to okay
excuse me mr nem switch get up
i kind of wish i had i was able to
experience that time with the these
strong personalities that i envisioned
in these chess tournaments and chess
clubs yeah he actually
he used to
step on his head you know because during
the games sometimes because he thought
that you can actually think better if
you have more blood in your brain
so you can do just headstands yeah
sometimes
you know
so i mean not all of his ideas were
great
but but would you dare to question him
no no no because you still want to
finish the tournament
yeah absolutely
oh i love these stories great great uh
personalities and taras was he polish
yeah i think he at least spent most of
his life there yeah and uh or what is
now poland yeah and uh yeah i never knew
that pontus
some of these stories are new to me yeah
no idea you you don't need to know the
mind that's fascinating i i don't think
it will help your child maybe you can
try it next time you know yeah i'm not
sure i could stand on my head
this is my kind of chess literature you
guys read all about the notation and the
games and i'll just read about these
stories so yeah the funny ones yeah
personality this is a personality
reading this little historical story is
quite funny yeah because i've always
just assumed you know that they were
like gentlemen you know had
cups of tea while they played these
extraordinarily long games and i always
thought that they came from rich
families
not true yeah not true whatsoever
a lot of chess players came from very
poor families and they fought their way
to the top and they you know they were
playing on the streets and they were
hustling and it was very interesting and
they had all sorts of you know they even
had physical fights amongst themselves i
was like what
but uh they did yeah and uh just sorry
to jump back to the position but we have
had one huge development and duda he's
actually created a threat but also he's
made a huge commitment he's blocked up
the king side the entire king side now
there's no pawn pushers especially for
white if you forget about the la the
left half of the board at the moment
white is completely stuck and that's why
magnus is thinking right now um if we
jump in we can explain what duder has
just done and it's all about this last
move pushing the jeep on forward locking
in his knight we actually mentioned
that this is an outpost it looks odd on
the side of the board but the black
knight actually doing a good job here of
keeping this white bishop in a cage but
uh the other reason apart from
immobilizing the white pawns is that
black wants to step to the side with his
queen and for example if white just
moves the king how do you stop this
threat against this pawn now it's not so
easy the pawn is attacked by knight and
by a queen and due to the fact that the
black knight kind of dominates so many
squares you can't defend your pawn in
the center
this could force magnus to
really i mean take
i mean i was going to say a big
commitment a big sacrifice but this just
looks wrong somehow planting the rook on
this square it can get captured by
black's knight but black doesn't even
need to rush to capture this rook and
without knights yourself with white i
don't think you'll get enough
compensation a rook for a night here so
big threat in the position the black
queen's stepping across attacking this
pawn and how do you defend it the
bishop's not coordinating look at this
sad piece in the corner
despite what the evaluation bar says i
think magnus in practical terms has huge
issues to deal with he needs to be very
accurate and energetic
because i can't see a way to guard this
pawn in the center but
could you kind of take inspiration from
other positions where you have a double
pawn and you just let it go
and and you just say i'm not going to
defend this pawn because if you think
about it you know there's a there's
going to be a trade in the position and
suddenly the light squared bishop will
have some squares yeah possibly and uh
maybe that's magnus's idea okay first he
drops his bishop back but what's his
reply to the queen sidestepping how are
you going to give away this pawn ivanka
defended twice i was i was thinking that
i was actually thinking of magnus's move
and the idea being that you then just
step back with the queen to the to a
dark square and then the idea is uh
after knight takes pawn
you don't capture that knight and you
said you capture sorry yeah you capture
the
the knight with the dark square bishop
and uh after that's been done
hopefully you have a nice square
on the f5 square to
put a look on the board yeah you can use
this square as a launching pad maybe i
mean it's still super complicated it
looks quite good for white here but the
black knight could maybe jump in uh so
just trying to destabilize your control
of this square it's so complicated right
now from a strategic point of view it
looks like magnus might have to
sacrifice a pawn but does doodo really
want to take it that's the question and
just while you were talking there your
bank as well um as well as kind of
capturing this i was thinking maybe
you'll move but now now yeah it suddenly
occurred to me when you said that just
lifting the rook up the board utilizing
the fact that you've cut the queen's
coordination with her knight in the
center and now if the rook is captured
then whoops suddenly the white bishop
finally pounces and rather than being
that sad piece in the corner that i
talked about the bishop creates a pin
and wins this black knight next and if
white gets two bishops for a rook white
is just winning so there are some tricks
in the position it's getting really
sharp and tactical right now and uh if
duder plays this move that we're
expecting bringing the queen across
magnus might have to find an idea a
flashy idea like that one just to make
sure that he gets enough compensation
for the pawn that's about to drop in the
center
uh yeah bishops vs knights we're
learning a lot yeah already
instructive stuff what do you think the
result will be right now we know that if
magnus wins this game it will be over
he's going to be the winner of the first
uh match
i'm hesitant to predict anything here i
i i think it all depends on the next
five six moves already it's quite a
critical moment
if you had to predict yeah because it's
also this how how do that wants to go on
with this you know
because either he can really go for this
uh the line we showed something yeah
which looks a bit dangerous also
or he can try for his last game with the
white pieces you know
because he i mean he can just play f6 or
something and just sit and i i i don't
after f6 i mean what can white really do
that's a good point so if black just
kind of fixes the structure just sits
and waits and does nothing maybe white
doesn't have a plan to improve yeah
maybe white is relying uh magnus is
relying on dude actually getting
ambitious and doing something in order
to try and win yeah i mean it's a little
bit like when you play soccer or you
counter attack
you basically just let the other team
you know have the ball and you
counter-attack
yeah that's a bit like how magnus is
playing right now that's a really good
analogy actually um he's just letting
dude dance around with the knights dance
around with the queen create some
threats but he's just sitting and
waiting for his moment to uh kind of get
the ball back and
go on the counter and okay black's
knight jumping in i don't think white
wants to part with his dark squared
bishop uh i think white darts where
bishop is going to move away from the
threat of the capture due to meanwhile
slightly shaking his head
maybe his idea is that once the white
bishop moves away the black knight is
going to go back where it came from and
just like pontiff said just maintaining
the status quo
not doing anything and
maybe that makes sense
because you do have a white in the final
game exactly i think he's shaking his
head because he he can't win you know
but but uh
i i would expect him
well but it minus you never know i mean
you saw how he played in the
game you know you never know but but
it's not a bad result to just repeat the
moves and take next scheme because i
don't think my new strategy has really
worked out very well here what would you
do if you would do that and you see
magnus is down on the clock two and a
half minutes would you take risks or
would you just yeah get out of this game
but i was going to say
magnus beat me to it i was going to say
you know you can kind of invert the move
order though and do as magnus is done
treat the queen and now you have the
idea idea of dropping the bishop back
and maybe dude has to go for this plan
that uh pontius mentioned just sitting
and waiting and he's doing that with his
king the white bishop retreating now and
uh yeah if you keep your black queen
where she is you can always recapture if
white ever gets tempted to take the
black knight on the side of the board
you capture back with your queen you
don't want to take with a pawn uh you
want to take with your queen and
still pretty solid white cannot really
challenge for the dark squares once he
trades off his star squad bishop
and uh yeah magnus
i do like the fact that he just showed
he's not willing to go for the draw
immediately he doesn't want to repeat
the moves it's still going to be hard
for him to break through look how
blocked it is now the pawn structure
it's hard for white to push any pawn the
only pawn white can ever push is the b
pawn he has to arrange that though it
takes a long time to but he might he
might go for it you know
how he is i think he's going for it you
know probably
he's going to
support the pawn and then he's going for
this
probably because he seems to be in
fighting mode
today so as we mentioned white's only
possible winning plan is to push this
pawn forward at the right moment but you
need to defend the pawn next to it first
by shuffling the rook across eventually
pushing this pawn even then you need to
decide what to do afterwards with your
pawns
so it takes a while but meanwhile duda
uh okay he's retreating his knight this
direction okay maybe magnus can build up
for this pawn push later as well as this
one
magnus is the one with the uh kind of
cards up his sleeve later sometimes he
can also push the pawn directly yeah
that's what i'm saying you can just do
that yes thinking
and
because you can't take the pawn out on
the edge there so yeah well you can do
it but you then you have to uh
protect it with the other pawn
this is only going to end badly for
black
looks
uh looks very badly
wow magnus really going for the win i'm
not happy with the draw here uh in this
position the black knight didn't
sideline itself it would have been on a
really bad square there it retreated and
magnus trying to open up lines pushing
pawns it looks odd to kind of trade off
black's double pawns here but the whole
idea is to open up lines for your pieces
and i mean firstly this one but also
slightly tempted this is a typical idea
in what we call the king's indian
opening to push pawns forward to open up
maximum lines for your rook later for
your queen and yeah wow could we see
this from magnus is he going to capture
this pawn the standard reply the
evaluation by shooting up
maybe one can push forward here as well
i love your idea david i think it's
great because otherwise paul if you go
porn taste porn well you know the black
knight can just hop back into the
original square and still hold
everything and you've yeah you've called
it david it's on the board yeah and this
is the idea borrowed from a similar
opening a different opening and that's
where pattern recognition comes in
useful uh the whole idea is just to open
up this line for the queen for example
if black who is opponent right now
captures this guy then suddenly after a
trade white queen pounces and she simply
she's going to win the game she's
attacking these two knights
she's attacking some really important
pawns as well this guy this guy
everything is falling suddenly in
black's camp and look at the black queen
meanwhile offside yeah not participating
so this is his idea you know to just uh
get the queen completely offside it's
quite yeah you know
magnus is very very deep in his strategy
you know so he's
he sees this kind of details that are
uh
david and me and javanka we also see but
one more or two moves later
and that's usually the problem you know
when you play with someone who's
stronger
when you see them
one move later
well that is why he is
world champion and this is super
dramatic for duda he
cannot lose this game if it does the
first match will be over minus will be
the winner and that means duda will have
to win the match tomorrow to take that
one to tie breaks and have a chance to
win his very first tournament in the
meltdown champions chess store and
remember our signed chessboard by magnus
carlsen is up for auction on
cctauction.com
the the that auction will close tomorrow
but this is super popular this
chessboard and all money goes to our
fundraiser for unicef and look at the
bar over two uh pawn advantage now four
magnus yeah i'm surprised it's that high
but maybe the position is just directly
very strong and duda with his last move
apart from recentralizing the black
queen we mentioned she was offside uh he
is initiating a bit of a threat black's
knight on the e file wants to capture
one of white's pawns in the center if
you look at the queens they're on the
same diagonal so actually white central
pawn is pinned and we're about to see
that idea in action white capturing upon
that you can't allow the white queen to
come up uh like we showed to the seventh
rank the white queen will just do all
the damage
so black's knight now needs to jump out
the way and capture a pawn uh i'm hoping
that we see it so
duda can just show off a little tactic
there using a pin
but how good is this trade because it
does feel like the position is opening
up and what does white have bishops
and
also
if you do go knight takes pawn there's
also pawn takes pawn the rook suddenly
springs into the game okay well we're
definitely gonna see
all this in action what is magnus going
to play yeah he has to do it because
there is also a fork you know that he's
threatening so that's also something
that he's after but it's it's uh magnus
was a counter i think to that fork so
yeah he's really
it's really tense now it's really tense
yeah the white queen could move as well
right now um so we should mention the
black knight is poisoned you cannot take
it because black's queen would go and
capture the white queen so a small trick
from duda but it's not gonna save him uh
magnus with a lot of tempting moves
right now if you move the white queen
the black knight really has to jump out
of the center as uh you guys mentioned
also white's fire advance pawn can go
and capture
another black pawn it's uh it's like
dominoes all the blacks pawns are
suddenly falling
but uh still
black is trying uh magnus still needs to
be accurate right now in order to kind
of solidify the advantage and even the
computer changing his mind slightly
going down and down yeah still very very
tense very sharp position
and magnus down to one minute as well
wow what a game
this is game three in the first match
you guys magnus carlson thinking he is
about to tick under
one minute on the clock and that's when
the drama really starts to happen but i
have to say it is young christopher duda
who looks the most worried to me
yeah it's a bit reminiscent of the
previous game where it was balanced
balanced balance for a long time and
then he just lost control and it
collapsed his position and it
looks like it's about to collapse for
black but i'm just trying to do some
calculation magnus trying to calculate
as well
still some stuff to worry about as
spontaneous mentioned black's knight
he's going to try and jump down
capture some pawns uh create those types
of forks that we're so used to seeing
in the rapid format and
it's not easy to calculate night jumps
it uh in this type of
position first of all but also when you
have 30 seconds on the clock yeah now i
suppose there is you know a very strong
move here but it's probably a typical
computer move because you really have to
calculate all this
oh you played this movie instead yeah
magnus raised his eyebrows you were
surprised by this ponce's just pushing a
black pawn yeah looks uh like it doesn't
help the position at all well it helps
time wise
so so i think that no but
this idea also that he used you know
even name switch and those guys would
approve of that
magnus actually running down to 20
seconds on the clock
and uh now
nothing how are things that i think
they've kind of clarified a little bit
and black is
holding
the struct well the peace formation
tightly and it's just uh there's no easy
way to break through although white does
have a very very scary pawn sitting
there on the c7 square
i think the bishops are coming now and
then this looks bad for duda
but
magnus time
uh you know because you still have to do
some good moves but this looks bad yeah
i am inclined to agree with you pontius
there uh but dude i think he's done as
much as he could i mean i don't think he
could have got any more out of this
position he's just trying to lock things
down and actually yesterday we talked
about superfluous knights so the black
knights kind of getting in each other's
way but they do defend each other very
well and uh that's what duda is relying
upon right now the black knights
defending each other
if you put extra pressure on one of them
though
then black's position could collapse and
okay here we do see according to
stockfish according to the computer
black has one move that's much better
than the rest and that involves it's not
easy black's knight on the b6 where
jumping into the white half of the board
defended by the black queen
i mean to me that looks
inhuman because that would allow white
to maybe sacrifice a rook for a couple
of nights
i don't think dude is going to find that
one every other move
gives white an advantage black's second
best move there according to the
computer is to retreat the knight in the
center of the board back to the f8
square near the black king near the
black queen
there is the rime knight on f8 there is
no mate so that would have some sense
behind it but that also looks really
passive and retreating knights as we
mentioned previously backward night
moves are some of the most difficult
moves to see visually in chess
if that night had a destination
you know if you could foresee something
then i i think that the night maybe
could move but the fact that they just
look like random night jumps no i don't
think duda will play and he doesn't he
instead pushes his pawn forward which to
me was the first move that i looked at
but i thought um not sure because that
pawn looks like it could be caught it
just gets captured and
actually that pawn push for black was
the third top computer choice but we did
see that this does favor white now and
uh white temporarily won porn up black's
idea though is that he's hitting the
white bishop and now the connection has
been cut between white's queen and the
far advanced white pawn so dude is
hoping that he can pick off this pawn
right now
how can magnus deal with both of those
threats simultaneously there's so many
tempting moves on offer you could move
that bishop you could even bring your
rook across attack black's knight you
can move the white queen
lots of choice and 14 seconds it's not
easy to make that decision and he
captures this black knight
wow
[Music]
interesting yeah
so he gives basically up the uh
he gives an exchange uh so he's going to
try to play
uh the pawn to to
protect his other pawn there yeah the
past one and then he's gonna
try to play in that position but it's
it's very uh
ah that's a decision
that's a commitment you can say it's a
harder it's a very committal uh
he's gonna do the probably the queen
move first no
ah he he can do this he just defends his
pawns yeah so uh magnus he's banking on
those two five they are definitely far
advanced yeah and they tie down one of
black's rooks
so uh the material count black is
actually a head black has a rook for
white's bishop and porn why is bishop
not great right now but it's all about
those two white pawns and
duder he's trying to hope that maybe he
can just stop the white rook getting
active
wow magnus just swinging it across
allowing maybe a rook check
but uh yeah the black queen the black
rook at the top of the board they're
gonna have to stay passive forever right
but it's a very committal decision by
miners can can mag can a duda just get
greedy and just capture some pawns you
know why not be
something
some material ahead for your woes might
as well suffer for something right
exactly for a reason um i think
but the the queen move no uh the queen
moved to to
yeah let's show this on the board yeah i
think that's a problem because then you
even get three points
and i think that's at least one too much
yeah as pontus mentions black can grab a
pawn so black would be a whole rook for
bishop up but after this queen move
attacking this queen oh sorry not that
one attacking the queen attacking the
pawn uh this just ends in a trade and
white would win now these three pawns
together are definitely going to
overwhelm this one black rook so this
was impossible uh duder has to keep his
rook on this square guarding the
possible exchange and after
uh we saw a couple moves the black queen
of rooks the white rook stepping across
the black queen moving now magnus is
trying to improve this bishop and if we
catch up with the current position
black's a bit stuck black has to do
something with his rook has to do
something with this queen but how
uh there's literally nothing you can do
with them and also this rook at the top
of the board mentioned uh it is
paralyzed and okay he's threatening at
least one check but this is easily
guarded by white's king and due to
shaking his head well the black queen
has to
make a retreat backwards it's all about
this pawn these two connected pawns now
are going to win the game for magnus
let's go back to the players
it's a brilliant move uh
you know this sacrifice is
it's really nice
it's really nice and okay instead of
retreating with the queen he's gone back
with his rook but magnus is hoping for
the queen trade he's got a plan i think
he's forcing the queen trade if if the
queen's come off
all white needs to do is actually give
up the bishop put that at the edge of
the board and then it will be two past
pawns or is that two is that too much
maybe yeah you can also also get the
bishop to uh the square just in front of
the rook yeah yeah yeah that's even
better you don't need to be flashy which
can be very very very
annoying because you can't move
basically so it's it's really sad that
one remaining black pawn on the queen
side on the left side of the board now
is about to drop that white bishop is
hitting it there's no way to defend it
you have to take it and then dude is
crying
three seconds two seconds he's gotta
give up his rook for the bishop okay he
goes active but this is not going to end
well it's not gonna work yeah he's
trying for some checkmates and magnus
doesn't even allow it look at that such
control yeah
i can shut the door on any entry for the
blackrook and now black really has to
get rid of that white bishop the white
bishop's about to take a pawn and win
the game and judah doesn't even continue
he doesn't try to save it he resigns